Peru's caretaker president Dina boluarte
is refusing to step down and is urging
Congress to allow early elections after
lawmakers voted against the proposal
unrest began when Pedro Castillo was
arrested for trying to illegally
dissolve Congress Castillo supporters
are calling his removal a coup 22 people
have died so far in clashes with police
police fire tear gas at demonstrators
blocking an airport in southern Peru one
of many protests that erupted across the
country after lawmakers removed former
president Pedro Castillo from Office
last week over 20 people have died in
the unrest and rights groups accused
authorities of using excessive force in
their response to the protests the
former president still has white support
especially among Peru's indigenous
communities
[Music]
[Applause]
protesters brought trucks to standstill
at this border crossing between Peru and
Bolivia
we want the immediate dissolution of
Congress we want Dina boloate to resign
we want new elections as soon as
possible
but Peru's Congress recently threw out a
bill that would allow early elections
caretaker president Dinuba huerte has
not caved to demands calling for her to
resign but she's calling on Congress to
reconsider the bill
there's a group that says Dana should
resign what does my resignation solve
does it solve the problem no it doesn't
we will be here firmly until Congress
decides to bring forward the elections
in the capital Lima a rally for peace
demonstrators called for Unity and
dialogue it's not clear if the caretaker
government can deliver that
[Applause]
all right well let's uh take a little
bit more of a look at this topic and
we're going to speak now to Dan Collins
he's a multimedia journalist and
filmmaker covering Latin America and
he's based in the Peruvian Capital Lima
welcome to DW so tell us why is the
parliament against the early elections
despite the president's calls for them
well Pablo there's a simple answer to
that and that that is that for most of
the Congress people uh they would lose
their jobs
um all of them will lose their jobs if
they were new elections because there
will be new general elections meaning a
new president and a new legislature
um so of course they would be out of a
job and and uh as it currently stands
they if there are no new elections they
would stay uh in Congress until 2026.
now in the vote on Friday uh which
rejected the proposal to bring forward
elections uh there was a small minority
that voted in favor of bringing forward
the elections um some of the Congress
people are saying perhaps more
responsibly that the the country needs
these new elections uh to get out of the
current crisis but this is part of the
problem and this is part of the um the
the lack of legitimacy which the
Congress has and all the Peruvian people
because the perception is
um and this is often backed up by some
some evidence uh that there is basically
as the Peruvian protesters have called
it Rat's Nest and I quote a ratsness of
corrupt interests and lobbies and that
is why many proving people feel that the
Congress doesn't represent their best
interests and uh that's why they feel
that elections are necessary and that
Congress should be closed
so if that's the feeling then what's the
solution really
well that's a very good question the
country is in flux at the moment as we
heard in the report uh Dina bolawarti
has said that she won't step down and
she has reiterated cause to bring
forward elections as the solution to the
current crisis she uh is also facing a
massive course to resign from the
protesters and that is largely due
because due to the handling of these
protests as we heard more than 20 dead
uh there are more than something like
350 injured and the roadblocks continue
uh there's a uh currently blocking the
the border crossing between Peru and
Bolivia and we have heard that rights
groups have also condemned the use of
excessive force by the security forces
in Peru and that's really that happened
as a result of a declaration of
Emergency on Wednesday
um a National Emergency which meant that
soldiers could be deployed to control uh
public disorder and that has led to a
significant rise in deaths and with each
protester that dies there's more outrage
the protests spread and the cause for
dinner to resign uh keep on
Dan Collins a journalist reporting from
the Peruvian Capital Lima thanks for
joining us on DW